[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the title of this presentation is please
don't mock me that's what my face looked
like seven years ago my name is Justin I
go by Searles my last name I'm most
internet things if you'd like my contact
info you may npm install' me i am the
creator and the current maintainer of
the world's second most popular
javascript mocking library if you don't
count jest or jasmine here's the
download chart that right there is sign
on the most popular one and that's us
test double way down there this was a
big day for us is the day we finally
caught up but the npm rebooted all their
servers so we're still fighting you
could totally help goose our numbers by
NPM installing testable today all of the
illustrations that i do will be just
musing testable by happenstance it's
what I know best I'm here today to
convince you that the popularity of a
JavaScript mocking library doesn't
matter and you should be saying well
you're just saying that because your
thing's not popular and you'd be right
but additionally I'm here because I've
been practicing test-driven development
with mocks for a decade now and I really
come to believe that literally nobody
knows how to use mocks and of course
that's a terrible thing to say I
shouldn't say that I should say
figuratively nobody knows and let's
break it down because there's a group of
people who can explain how to best mock
things in any given situation and
there's another group of people who
always mock things out consistently
unfortunately for all of us there's a
much larger group of people who use
mocking libraries without belonging to
either previous group and so you know
when we initially wrote test double J s
it was really to like target that
intersection of developers who already
knew really how to like make the most of
their tests and my goal is not just to
become more popular to grow the
intersection people who really
understand and get the most out of their
mocking library and them as a result the
most out of their tests so that's what
we're here to do today but to do that we
have to define a few terms first
whenever I say the word subject I'm
referring to the thing being tested like
a like an experimental test subject as
where it gets that name whenever I say
dependency like if you're testing a
module anything that that thing import
so relies upon that is external to it is
a dependency and whenever I say unit
test I'm not using a really like fancy
definition or nuance term really like if
you're invoking a function and you
assert certain things come out the other
end congratulations you have a unit test
the catch-all term for all types of
mocks is testing double whether you're
talking about a stub or a spy or a mock
or a fake but today I'm gonna like you
know disregard all of that and just use
mock because it's the most common
vernacular coincidentally and sort of
unfortunately from like a branding
perspective I'm also from a company
called test double we are not a mocking
library manufacturer instead we're
actually a consultancy and what we do is
we pair up with teams maybe like yours
who are looking for additional senior
developer talent and we join you on
contract to work alongside you get
things done and hopefully with an eye to
helping you make things better along the
way you can learn more about us online
this talk has four parts the first part
is obvious abuses of mocking we're gonna
move on to the less obvious abuses and
then we're going to move right along to
the questionable uses that might have
some value but people often mess up and
finally the one good use for mocking
that I found in you know all this
practice so first let's start with the
obvious uses and that is using partial
mocks so you like mocked out part of a
thing but left part of the other stuff
real and to illustrate let's say that
you run a park ticket kiosk machine
you know people tap on the screen and
then you know they say hey I'm 12 years
old and so we check our inventory module
to ensure that the child tickets are
available before we try to sell them if
they'd said they were 13 we check for
adult tickets and either way because we
want to like upsell them during the
checkout phase we make sure that we have
Express passes available to sell the
logic like might be implemented in code
like this you know if they're under 13
and sure we have a child ticket
otherwise ensure we have an adult ticket
the Express module thing is turned on
make sure we have those and so on and so
forth a test for this how would that
look well we'd create another test
module over here and we did invoke the
code just like we normally would but
what about this insurer child ticket
because it's like a Boyd function it
doesn't return anything useful so like
how would we assert on that well we
could mock out that method on the
inventory and then return back and
verify that that call took place and a
way to do that we just replace poke a
hole in reality replace that method and
then fit
code path me again we just invoke it
like normal and then you know testable
and a lot of mocking libraries come with
a way to like verify a particular
invocation happen just how you like it
for the other code path for the adult
we'd write another test case we poke a
second hole in reality and while we're
there we can make sure we don't call
that one during the child code bat that
wouldn't make sense and then mostly just
copy paste and then update the values we
can run this test great test passes
looks good
fortunately time marches on and you
didn't do anything but you get a phone
call that the build is broken and your
test is the one failing so you run the
test again and sure enough it's failing
in two places we're calling the adult
code the adult inventory insure adult
thing an extra time when we didn't
expect to and that doesn't make any
sense to us cuz we haven't changed this
code we look at it nothing's different
here so we look at the only thing that's
actually external still a real method
ensure Express pass that's still getting
called so that means we have to go now
load up this inventory module and we can
see the maintainer of that module
actually added an intrinsic call to
ensure adult ticket maybe they don't
want to sell Express passes if they're
out of stock and that might make sense
to them but like can we really blame
them for breaking our tests like were
they expecting this zombie half real
half fake inventory module to be
floating around somewhere probably not
so we don't have really any recourse
except to poke a third hole in reality
and we can make the test work but
something feels wrong it's almost like
our ship is sinking and our solution is
to poke more holes in it so in this case
you know the test felt good initially
because it was superficially simple it
was terse and only said what we cared
about but underlying that was that we
didn't really have good experimental
control from what we're trying to
specify so instead what I'd recommend
you do fake out the whole thing that way
it's really clear what the contract line
is and then require your thing and test
as usual in short if you have a
dependency and it's a totally real
dependency that's really easy to
maintain because we're used to invoking
code that's real if you have code that's
like a dependency that you've completely
faked out whether what the tool or not
at least you have total experimental
control so the expectations are clear
but if you have this like dependency
that's like half real a half fake it's
going to fail for surprising reasons and
you're gonna have a bad time the second
obvious abuse that I see of mocking is
people partially mocking out the actual
thing the subject the thing that they're
testing this advice is short please
don't fake out part of the thing
that you're testing you know I get
pushed back sometimes like oh well we
have a very very large module it's got
all these methods and they call each
other and there's just no other way to
get coverage of this little thing right
here so we need to poke holes here and
there and there to get our test running
a problem with that is like now you have
two problems you have a big thing that
nobody understands and tests of it that
nobody trusts so please don't do that
third obvious thing that we see is when
people replace some of a dependent of
the dependencies under tests but not all
of them for a given subject and so to
explain I'd like to use a word over
mocking if you've heard this term I
think it's kind of like a prevailing
ideology of how people think about
mocking and tests as if it's an
affordance to be moderated like you have
this manometer
that's like slowly building up as you
mock things but watch out because you
don't want to over mock you've crossed
some invisible threshold so don't do
that
and it's a strange way to think about it
so let's talk about it let's say that
you write a system that handles airplane
seat reservations and your great your
pair programming together at work and so
you think about the different
dependencies that you need to implement
this subject that's under test and then
you talk about the different test cases
that you need to implement and because
you're pairing you try to normalize on
approach and so you know person on the
right says hey I like mocking out my
dependency isn't the person on the left
you know doesn't like mocking tries to
avoid so you know you're pairing so what
do you do you compromise and just mock
out half the things that is not a laugh
line that's just how people really do
this so you might got half the things
and as far as this ideology of mock
commoners ago you're looking good you're
46 percent or whatever but time passes
and you get another call because the
build is failing and it's your fault and
so you can see here you know request see
our module is calling this seat map with
a particular address and then it gives
the seat object back and you can see
it's like a string right well the
problem is that they've updated that
contract and now they expect it to be a
- arised address and so our test blew up
well the person on the right who prefers
to isolate their dependency says hey
this failure has nothing to do with the
subject and you know she'd be right like
you see the seat number is just kind of
passed in like a baton we don't do any
of the string manipulation stuff here
and so she changes that real dependency
to a fake dependency fixes the test now
more time passes but this time worse
thing production is broken so let's dig
in you know here we have
this thing that actually fires the book
seat and for obvious reasons we've
knocked that out and you can see if it
takes these three arguments well the
maintainer of that transposed the second
and third argument for whatever reason
and our test continued to pass it was a
fantasy green test and as a result
production blew up because the build was
Green now the person on the Left who
hates mocking would point out hey this
wouldn't have happened if we hadn't
knocked this thing out and he's right -
so he goes into the test and replaces
the fake thing with the real thing and
gets you back to passing and I don't
think this is what people meant by
ping-pong pier programming but this kind
of passive-aggressive back-and-forth is
exactly what you get people don't know
why they're using a particular tool for
a given job instead and this is kind of
maybe surprising to hear like a test
that never fails is a bad test because
it hasn't told you anything it's just
consumed countless cycles of cloud cpu
time in your CI server instead you know
it's gonna fail there hopefully it'll
fail so think at the time that you're
writing it what should failure mean for
this test and design that instead of
like how you actually write tests for
example if you're writing a unit test
it's all wired up all those dependencies
are real sure nothing is mocked but
let's think about like when it fails and
you know intuitively you can say well
it'll fail whenever the subject or its
dependencies logics changes that's great
it encourages you to be mindful though
of what I call redundant code coverage
and that is if you have a module that's
depended by 35 different things and you
change that module you don't want to set
yourself up for a situation where you
have to now go update 36 different tests
so be thinking about that now if we have
isolated unit tests where all the things
are faked out 100% mocks or our my
comedy readings are beeping loudly or
something but when it fails we have a
clear definition of what failure means
it means in the contract between the
subject and its dependency has changed
and so it should encourage us though to
like be mindful that like we probably
want to have another smoke test some
integrated thing that just make sure
that when everything is plugged together
the app basically seems to work so
that's important too but what do we what
do we do in this case we're half the
things are real and half the things are
fake you know it looks good under the
prevailing ideology of like you know
mocking is moderation but when does it
fail well it can fail for like multiple
numerous nonsensical reasons and so it
should encourage us do not write just
like this so
please don't do that and so instead of
critiquing how much mocking you see in
the codebase critique why people are
using box at all like what's the broader
strategy here and I guarantee you'll
have more productive discussions the
common thread between all three of these
things is that I think that you know
just we all tend to have this sensation
that like realism is very important in
testing because we want to make sure
things are gonna work and they're not
gonna explode but that can actually
cause problems where we forget that what
testing is really about is like setting
up clear experimental control to get
consistent results that tell us
something that we need to know and
that's important to all right so let's
move on to like the less obvious abuses
and that's I want to start with talking
about mocking out third-party libraries
so say that you depend on an awesome Lib
it's an NPM package and there's
references to it all over your codebase
it's got a kind of funky API though
first you call it and then you pass it a
config file so we read that from disk
that returns an instance of the library
that we can then call an optimized
method on and we get all these really
cool interpreter hints that we can use
to speed up our code problem with that
is that song and dance is kind of weird
and so it's really hard to mock awesome
live and here's like how you might you
know try to go about it you fake up the
file system and then you fake out
awesome Lib and then you create a an
artificial instance to represent
creating one then you fake out the file
system to say hey if we pass the right
path I'll give you something to
represent the config and then when we
get the config will return that instance
and then when you call optimize on the
instance we'll call back with some hints
that's a lot of setup and so you'd be
right to look at that and get really
frustrated how much you know mocking
logic you have at the top of your test
and a lot of people complain about that
but the root cause here has nothing to
do with the mocking library the root
cause is that that was hard to use code
and that like mocking libraries job is
to specify interactions you have with
public API s and so what the mocking
library is doing is it screaming at you
that this is a bad design so instead we
just like force it and so we like copy
paste that set up across all of our
tests and and you know JavaScript we
march along very quickly new major
update is announced to Awesome Lib and
we're really excited that maybe they'll
fix this for us but all they did was
change the callbacks to promises and so
now we have to go over here and J and
just add then resolve so that these are
not
promise resolutions and we have to do it
in 18 different places javascript
marches on and nobody uses awesome lib
anymore we find out that like the new
hotness is mind blow and and everyone's
pressuring us to go and switch as fast
as possible and so now we're just angry
because we have all this pain festering
throughout our system what I found is
that like if code is hard to mock and
it's something that you own it's a
module that's in your codebase and you
can readily change it that that feedback
is fantastic because the remedy has
improved the code design but if it's a
third party thing that you don't control
what are you gonna do like send a pull
request and ask them to change their
public API adjust for you no it's it's
not gonna work out so well it's it's an
example of useless pain and how people
go about testing is full of useless pain
so be on the lookout because it's money
out the window so if you care about
testing you need to minimize the amount
of drudgery or else people are gonna
come to value at less and view it as a
waste of time so instead of mocking out
third-party things I write little
wrappers for them instead an example of
this one might here be here just as
Questor it off to the periphery of my
application this is the only time I'm
ever going to require awesome live in my
app and instead I'm going to expose this
simple awesome callback API that I wish
that it did and sweep under the rug all
the other complexity that I have to have
additionally doing this by habit gives
you some like additional mental space to
think hey maybe we should be caching
this file a read that's kind of silly or
you know we could translate the awesome
Lib errors into something that's like
more concordant with like how we write
error handling for the rest of the
application and you can just do all that
there additionally all that test setup
you know that gets a lot simpler right
because now we're just faking out
something that we understand that's
simple to use and create so much extra
room in each test to be thinking about
like what am I actually trying to
specify instead of getting distracted in
all sorts of mocking related rabbit
holes and you don't have to worry about
writing unit tests of these things for
the same reason you're not going to
improve their design just trust the
framework to work because otherwise this
is money out the window then the next
lesser of the obvious things that I see
folks do is when they read a lot of code
that tangles up logic with delegation
let's explain so let's say that you own
a fencing studio and you rent out swords
and your boss says hey how many swords
are we gonna have on Tuesday and so
instead of like being like a normal
person you write it function that takes
in a date
you call a network requests to fetch out
all the rentals that are currently
outstanding you get those back and then
you filter those down first by
calculating the duration of that rental
and then figuring out when did the
rental start so that I can figure out
what's going to be do then plucking the
swords out of it now you also have an
inventory the stuff that's not currently
being rented so you call that - you get
the inventory back you can catenate the
- and then those are the swords that
you're gonna get back so you can report
success how might you test this well you
start by creating a fake rental object
properly that has the right properties
on it you stub that out so that fetch
rentals calls back with it when it's
invoked you step out the inventory as
well maybe with a second sword and then
with a very particular date argument you
call the subject under test and you
assert that like you get the two swords
that you expect and this works and you
have some other test cases - so it's a
little complicated time passes though
it's working fine and somebody on the
team points up hey you know we can speed
this code path up now because we have a
primed synchronous cache that you can
call you can go into the code and you
can eliminate one of these network
requests so you just call that instead
I've done this and now that looks good
the code is faster but of course what it
broke the test so we're we're frustrated
by that if you look here yes sure enough
we are we are mocking out this other
thing for that part of the behavior it's
not going to do what we want the test is
gonna break and somebody on the team
might point out like oh well the test is
coupled to the implementation this is
very bad this is a common criticism
against mocking but I don't think it's
necessarily bad I think it's a little
bit of naive criticism because like we
write a test and then we assume that
it's going to save us in 800 different
types of change that the system might
undergo but like at most it can help us
from one or two so when you're writing
tests think about like you know this
test is going to make me safe for a
certain kind of change maybe but design
that upfront so for example if you have
your writing test or something it
doesn't have any dependencies it's
probably a pure function specifying
logic and that means that if the rules
to that logic change the tests need to
change if you're just refactoring from a
for loop to a for each or something
you're probably going to be fine but
like if you're adding a grace period to
these rental durations the rules of the
game change so you have to update all of
your code examples it is coupled to the
implementation in that way so if you
have like another test though and you're
mocking all
dependencies of the subject what it does
is it specifies those relationships and
so when the contracts change the test
needs to change the previous example
like if the duration has a grace period
one of its dependencies that's internal
to that that's that's arm's length we
don't have to worry about that this test
should keep passing but if we literally
change what we depend on to do our job
of course that just is going to change
gonna break and you need to fix it where
this really flies off the rails is when
people are right subjects that have you
know both the mocking out dependencies
and also implement some amount of logic
it gets really painful so to illustrate
our own example does this right we have
this current inventory we're calling
this fetch rental service that we're
calling but then we kind of like a joint
on to that this responsibility to like
calculate windswords or do and you can
see it right here it screams off the
page if you know what to look for you
know I've got network requests here and
I got all this logic and it's same thing
in the test I've got the network
requests here and then all this logic
floating around and what this is what
we've called it like if we're given a
design critique of this module we'd say
that this is mixed levels of abstraction
because two of the things that we're
doing are happening with like business
domain objects that speak in our
language like like like peers throughout
the app but then we're also dealing with
all this primitive gunk we're
implementing logic and multiplying
primitive you know values like integers
and such and that's a classic example of
a code smell and the way that you'd
remediated that code smell is by
spinning off that third thing so that
sword stock now has a single
responsibility its job is to break up
the work into these three other parts
and let them do the real heavy lifting
and and that thing that we just spun off
is now a lot easier to maintain because
it just takes in a couple arguments
spits out an outcome it's a pure
function really easy to test really easy
to maintain so if a test is specifying
pure logic there's no easier test to
write inputs and outputs there's there's
nothing else to deal with if it tests
specifies relationships and only
relationships those are completely under
your control they tend to not change
unless the contract changes but if it
specifies both you're gonna have really
really long test cases that change for
all sorts of different reasons it's more
useless pain so if you need a sticky
note to like put on your team wall or
something I encourage everyone to write
functions that either do something or
delegate to someone but
both all right the last lesser of the
obvious things that I see people do is
when they mock dependencies like halfway
down the call stack so what I mean by
that let's take that we have writing a
system to handle travel expenses
so we have our invoicing app and then
we're communicating via HTTP to get some
JSON back from our expense system and so
we have a method send invoice which
calls build invoice which calls to
filter the approved ones should groups
in buy purchase order and then loads the
expenses and then that breaks out to
HTTP to like load them from the expense
system and then all the way back up the
chain with this intermediary D or data
models for those actors so you might ask
hey I'm writing a test to this send
invoice thing which layer do I mock it
it's a good question so what my answer
depends on what kind of test you're
writing
so if you're writing an isolated unit
test as you develop it I would always
say depend not out the direct dependency
because you're gonna get designed
feedback what it's like to invoke that
thing and the test data is going to be
completely minimal so the contract
between those two things is really clear
if you're trying to get regression
safety just make sure that things work I
would either mock out nothing or say
mock out only like external system so
that you're using the system like a real
user would benefits here are that like
your test data is going to be
representative of real life they're
probably gonna like look like HTTP
fixtures and additionally if it breaks
you know what that means it doesn't work
anymore but I see a lot of teams reach
for the convenience of just mocking it
whatever arbitrary depth comes to mind
and this is kind of the worst of both
worlds because when it fails it doesn't
mean anything other than somebody might
have changed something and now you have
to update this test or like the the data
that you're loading the fixtures are all
kind of coupled to that thing and so
your data could fall out of sync at any
moment and yet this is probably like 80%
of the way that I see people knocking
out data providers and their JavaScript
apps so to summarize if you mock out a
direct dependency the failure is
meaningful because it means the contract
had changed
if you mock out an external system again
it's a meaningful failure it means your
thing is broken but if you mock out this
intermediate layer it probably just
means that you have to go and do the
chore of like updating that test now a
probably it's going to like your eyes
will glaze over when the build fails cuz
you know you just have to go update
stuff the common thread between all of
these is that when we reach for mocks is
just a tool of convenience they undercut
our overall test strategies return on
investment and
tends to make mocks a four-letter word
on a lot of teams I said that just
realizing Mach was already a four-letter
word but you get my point let's move on
to the questionable uses of mocking
first one I see a lot is when people
write mocked out tests for existing code
bases let's say that you work at an
internet of things doorbell company and
your startups you got a lot of spaghetti
code but you just got a lot more funding
so you can finally write all those unit
tests that you never did and you've been
really ashamed of the fact that you at
0% code coverage in your system and so
you think well what's the first test
that I could write let's write something
real simple and integral to like what
our system does that when you ring the
door the ding count goes up and so we
require a doorbell and then we require
the thing that rings the doorbell we
create a new doorbell we passes the
subject and make sure that the ding
count has been incremented we run this
test and oh well we got the stupid error
because you got to have a door for a
doorbell no problem I'm gonna import the
door it's actually the door passes to
the doorbell run my test except for the
fact that a door requires a house it's
fine
you're gonna import the house
instantiate a passing the door which
passes the doorbell oh just passing the
subject run the test and a house
requires a paid subscription network
connection to this other service and you
know what now you're just upset and
frustrated because like the thing about
untested code is very often lots of code
paths especially when we're creating
values are only ever invoked in one
place and so this kind of crapped you
can just like accrue one of the best
things about testing is all your code
gets like lots of exercise in lots of
different contexts so you're
incentivized to make value objects that
are cheap and easy to construct so the
right thing to do here is like make your
value objects easier to construct but of
course what they do instead is they
knock all that stuff out replace it with
a fake doorbell set add in count on it
and then get to get to passing but this
is not the right reaction I like if I
had to summarize that into like a motto
I say like mock out independencies mock
out things that have like application
logic that do the work but pass in real
values that type information should be
valuable it should be easy to construct
them and besides tests like this aren't
going to get you they're not gonna move
the needle very much in this person
situation instead what you probably want
with an untested system is more safety
to aggressively refactor it in which
case I recommend you to
the distance so think of ring Bell in
the context of its application maybe
there's an HTTP router in front of that
and then we could write a test that runs
in a separate process that interrogate
that thing just the way a real user
would so we can send a post request to
like exercise the behavior that we want
to test you know assume that maybe
writes to a data store somewhere and
then after we've done that we can run
another request and see whether or not
they'd had the impact that we want it or
we maybe could look directly at the
database and this is gonna provide way
more safety to like actually start
changing and improving the design of
that ring bell subject now integrated
tests they are indeed slower and they
fail for more nonsensical reasons but
they do provide more refactor safety and
if you knew you're in this situation
they're going to be a way more bang for
your buck from a code coverage
perspective and actually providing some
sort of sense that your build means
something
the next questionable use I see people
do a lot is enabling highly layered
designs by leveraging mocks you know
something I've seen over the years is
that testing tends to push us to make
smaller objects so instead of like one
gigantic horse sized duck module we're
writing like a hundred duck-sized horse
so instead of having a gigantic order
j/s method with like 800 methods all
over it we might have like a bunch of
carefully named different
responsibilities in our app in separate
files and so forth now I can talk all
day about like why big modules are bad
but it's not the case that smaller
modules are better just because they're
smaller in fact if you're like every
time you pick up a new feature and you
go to implement it you're just kind of
creating these six cookie cutter objects
over and over and over again you're not
actually like improving the design
that's just large objects with extra
steps like you're still you're adding a
bunch of new direction you're adding a
bunch of files you're not really like
improving things so you might ask hey
what is this like unsolicited design
feedback have to do with mocking well
I'll tell ya if we were testing all this
stuff and we made a change to this like
a bottom layer that's really heavily
dependent on module of course we would
have to update that test but normally it
would also fail all the tests of the
things and depend on that thing and
would disincentivize from a layering
like this but mocking comes in a lot of
teams will be like alright cool i can
just fake out all the layers beneath me
and so that means that i can create
these arbitrarily injury
stacked up applications with with the
test not no longer providing me that
feedback so mocks actually add a blind
spot to teams in this situation and I
would caution you to that like layering
is not the same thing as abstraction
you're not doing domain modeling if all
you're doing is adding more and more
layers of indirection so of course I
love small modules I love small things
make small things but make sure that
they're meaningful that they sell of a
distinct purpose the name means
something and that you're not just like
creating a bunch of files for no reason
so what I'd rather see is an application
that only has like one controller but
like it knows who to call at the right
time so you know maybe there is a
responsibility to create an order and
then I just use that it's like an escape
hatch like a main method for the create
order thing so that it can only focus on
what's special about creating orders and
doesn't get sucked into all this sort of
like carrying the water that is
necessary for every single feature if
you're just kind of copy and paste the
same stack over and over again so if
you're in this situation and you're
finding that like you're isolated unit
tests aren't providing you with like
useful design feedback they're not
providing you value don't do it anymore
in fact maybe question whether or not
like your architecture is too repetitive
and redundant and could be improved
the last questionable thing I see is
folks who rely too heavily on call
verification where you know a mocking
library lets you verify that a call
happened a lot of people will get really
excited about that and I'm a big
believer like in general terms that we
come to value whatever it is we measure
and an assertion is a measurement and so
our assertions tend to steer the design
of our systems so let's say that we run
a petting zoo
and you were given a copy of test double
J s and your birthday so you're really
excited to go mock things out and you
know you're what you're excited about is
like you love petting the pets but now
you can finally assert when that happens
so you know you put the sheep one time
you pet the llama you can even say hey I
put the Sheep two times you don't pet
the crocodile you can ascertain that -
sorry crocodile
we could write a test for this right you
know like when we passed in this like
function a kid and the sheep it'll
return true as well as for the llama and
false for the crocodile we invoked that
subject with those three animals and
then we verify that the sheep and the
llama got pet but the crocodile didn't
and to implement something that passes
this test we import for those two things
and then we pass in the kid and the
animals for each of those animals
it likes the animal that pets the animal
now we got to a passing test great
there's one problem though which is like
kids have dirty hams and the pet
function doesn't say how dirty and we
gotta clean the animals in this petting
zoo and so you just have to guess and so
you set up a cron job to hose down the
llamas every night at 10:00 p.m. which
is a tremendous waste of water so we
want to do better what happened here is
actually an example of like where tools
can mislead us because tools are awesome
because they save us time by reducing
the necessary thoughts and actions we
need to take in order to get a job done
but if we're not careful sometimes our
tools can actually eliminate useful
thoughts and and that happened in this
case now just because you're able to
verify calls with your mocking library
you have to realize that it might
encourage you to write more impure
functions and impure functions those
that have side effects are harder to
maintain than pure functions those that
return values because nowhere when I was
writing this code I think to ask
hey what value should pet returned
because I had a convenient way to assert
that it was just called and if I had to
think about that I'd say well you know
the pet function should probably take an
animal and then return a dirtier version
of that animal I guess so let's pretend
we did that and here we're gonna stub
out that when we pet the sheep we get a
dirty sheep when you pet the llama we
get a dirty llama now we care about this
result and we're gonna assert that we
get a dirty sheep a dirty llama on a
clean crocodile so other parts of our
system know which animals to clean at
the end of the day we update the
implementation like this first we're
gonna take away this for each whenever
you see a for each anywhere any kind of
loop you know that like your application
is just screaming side effects because
it doesn't return anything so we're
going to change that to a map instead
and trade one array for another and
return the value of that pet call and
the parse of the kid doesn't like the
animal will just return the animal as it
was and this pad passes the test so now
we know to wash these first two and we
can spare the third there's just one
last thing here is if you actually run
this test you're you know really big
warning up at the top because I'm gonna
tell you that you stubbed and verified
exactly the same call and that that was
probably redundant and what does that
mean well if you look at this test we're
now like verifying explicitly every
single thing that happens but we no
longer need to be because we're like
also stubbing these things and asserting
on the values
come back and so it's almost provably
redundant now we can just remove that
stuff simplified the test and so in
general after years and years and years
of writing and using mocking libraries
I've come to view verification as just
the assertion of last resort only if it
really makes sense for the thing I'm
calling to not return a value or if I'm
it's out of my hands out of my control
do I actually write assertions using
verification the common thread between
all three of these things is we forget
that like mocking libraries were
invented to provide rich design feedback
to improve the design the simplicity of
our systems and if we ignore that then
we're just introducing yet more useless
pain all right so that was like a lot of
things to not do the one thing that I
really like and let's talk about that so
I was really inspired by this book
called growing object-oriented software
guided by tests by Steve Freeman and NAT
Price years ago and I've iterated on it
enough that Matt has kindly asked me to
call what I do something else so I call
a discovery testing we're gonna do a
quick demo so suppose that you write
conference talks but it takes too long
there's just too much emoji and fiddling
and stuff so you decide let's meet it
and so you take something that loads up
all your notes you run it through a
sentiment I'll sentiment analyzer to
find what emoji should match up and then
you generate a keynote file you know if
we start a test like this and we're
practicing discovery testing I always
start with the setup at the very top
layer and I ask myself what's the code
that I wish I had because I'm lazy and
I'm also relatively incompetent and like
when I'm looking at a blank code listing
I just panic and assume that I'm too
dumb to figure it out but if I could
just say hey I wish I had something that
loads notes and something that pairs
those notes up with emoji to create
slides and then finally something to
create the keynote file for me that I
can understand and then you know I load
up my subject and I can start thinking
about the test well of course the test
should be it creates the keynote from
the notes I run this test and it fails
because I'm talking about code that
doesn't exist so it says hey this module
isn't real so I just touch it and I run
it again and then this other one the
second pair emoji isn't real touch it
run again and then create file isn't
realized cetera et cetera and I got that
too passing and what I love about that
is that it gives me small incremental
forward progress throughout the day even
if all I accomplished just then was like
the plumbing of my application it feels
like paint by number and
you know programming is an area of just
professional life where we I really wish
that things could we'd get more feedback
through the day like hey good job bad
job and sometimes people go days weeks
months without any real feedback that
they're on the right path so so testing
this way provide like soothes my anxiety
and now you know I've broken this work
up to at least three responsibilities
here so I can start writing the actual
tests now I assume I'm gonna need
something to represent notes so I create
like an ode note domain module and when
I stub you know for given a search
string you know I should call back with
those notes I assume I'm gonna need like
a slide value as well and so when I call
this pair emoji thing with the notes it
just should return these slides
synchronously I call my subject with
that search string and the given path
that I want to ready to file - and then
I verify that create file was called
with those slides at that path run my
test again and here's the message I've
been working for it's all this time
right I expected this to be called with
these slides at that path I can make
this test pass by importing the three
you know still empty modules we're gonna
fake that out at run time passing the
the topic to load notes get the callback
callback create the slides and then
create the file with those slides in
that given path I run this test and now
it passes now you'd be right to ask like
that was a lot of words and minutes for
five lines of code like how is this
actually a productive use of your time
and the answer is I've actually done a
lot of work here just by thinking
through all these things I just like
agreed to like hey this is our public
API of these two strings I know that
when I pass a topic into load notes I
get notes back I know pair emoji trades
notes for slides and I know that we
passed slides and path to some other
responsibilities the subject at this
point the entry point is done I'm not
kidding when I say often never look at
that top level again I've successfully
broken it up into three problems the
work is broken down into three things
that we know the contract so you don't
have to worry about the fiddly bits
giving all tangled together at some
point they have different jobs that we
know in advance and we already proven
out the contract between those things so
we know what to call them with because
there's already something calling them
and that's great so additionally you
know we we sussed out a couple of value
types that we want to be passing through
these methods you know we have some
notes and
and the next step is like it's a tree
right it's just recursion so we ask like
okay so how do you what do we want load
notes to do well it's got to read from
some note file parse our outline and
then flatten those points so that we're
having a linear presentation and the
first is IO and the second and third are
just pure functions and the writing test
for pure functions like we talked about
it's really easy so we want to maximize
those the pear emoji thing maybe we
tokenize those notes and then we run
that off to a sentiment analyzer and
then we convert them to slides and the
first things are pure function the
second thing is a good probably gonna be
a wrapper because I don't want to figure
out how to do sentiment analysis oh not
another pure function this last bit you
know we want to build some kind of
layout from those slides like text goes
on top emoji down here or whatever then
we need to generate Apple script
commands so we can actually know like
have a big array of like everything we
need to automate with keynote and then
finally something who's responsible for
rifling through all of those commands
and and generating the file for us the
first and second again pure functions
real easy and the last one would just
like shell out to this thing called OS a
script that's gonna like open up Apple
script in automate keynote
what I love about this process is it
gives me reliable incremental progress
throughout my day what shakes out the
other end is a bunch of single
responsibility units with intention
revealing names the the organization of
all these small things is actually
discoverable like if I create a new
directory every time i recurse well if
you're reading my code you only have to
dive as deep as you seem to be
interested and to answer the question
you're looking for it separates out all
of the values from the logic by default
so it doesn't tangle those up and I
spend most of my time writing really
easy like synchronous pure functions
which are the easiest kind of code to
maintain that's all I got so I thank you
for being patient really grateful that
you showed up at a talk late in the day
you know like I mentioned testable we're
a consultancy if your team is looking
for you know experienced developers
maybe you're only thinking about hiring
but you might be open to talking to us
instead about how we might be able to
help out and integrate with your team
I'd love to meet you check out our
website we're also hiring so if you'd
like to work remotely you kind of share
our passion for improving how the world
write software and you want to share
your experience with others check out
our join page video of this talk I've
got a previous one from a cert J s in
February I've already I buffered
so it's gonna be tweeting the video link
momentarily to my Twitter accounts URLs
would also love to see your feedback
through our website forum also I've got
brand new testable stickers are a new
alternate logo I'm gonna be here all
week and if you ask for a sticker I'd be
happy to give you one there's just one
last thing I want to share before we go
which is my wonderful wife Becky down in
front she put in a lot of work this
morning I took a lift out to the store
and she she just for your all's benefit
I'm not the generous type but she is but
I am like the head of marketing for
testable so I saw an opportunity and she
purchased like every last bug spray at
the target nearby so Thank You Becky
and then I affixed branded stickers on
to each of them so here's the deal
because there's not enough of these for
everybody if you come and meet us at
dinner and you talk a little bit and you
say just enough to demonstrate that you
actually showed up to a 5:45 p.m. talk
we will happily give you a bug spray
until we run out of them that's our
little gift to you thank you for your
patience I had a really good time
speaking here today
[Music]
you